yeah you're hungry on you yeah
yeah you're not going to solve our shift
aren't you and you're only earning seven
pound an hour yeah you can't even afford
to eat here you're hungry aren't you nah
okay you look like you've played that
way try to stop chow mein yeah you know
that's my favorite you know
[Music]
right guys we're back with another
Banger another Banger as we would say
[Music]
oh what days
um yeah and as you already know we hit
it straight from the jump yeah yeah
foreign
[Laughter]
as you know guys you go straight we go
straight to the source and the question
of the week was you like this one
craziest thing you found on someone's
phone part two get oh [__] after you
after I thought you were gonna do that a
couple weeks ago yeah part two wow we
haven't done this one in over like a
year or so and that one slap slap that
one was my I think my favorite question
of the week of all time I've never seen
you laugh like that your eyes nearly
fell out yourself the flipping um Gunter
grenades from Somalia grenades from
Somalia sent me yeah yeah that will
always be like a top five moment yeah
yeah yeah
right craziest thing you found on
someone's phone part two
in his notes he had a list of porn stars
he's ever watched and rated them out of
10.
wow that's that's a different level yeah
raise them out ten a man said Lisa Ann
yeah
Sarah J seven seven depending it was a
BBC today yeah it depends Oh my days I
found naked photos of my dad's side
chick on my uncle's phone
wild that's horrible the rebel Shadow
His red was deep in it dad's side chick
on my uncle's phone that's damn how do
you notice it's that side chick hey
that's a close-knit family them all
apart from the mum that's a close-knit
family wow wow wow
a video of my boyfriend getting his ass
ate from the eater's POV
[Laughter]
nah bro she put the Heartbreak emoji
from the eater's POV oh brother that's
so close you're watching oh man just
look back oh God from the eaters POV is
hilarious that's so funny when I was 14
my boy had a step-by-step manual on how
to lick his girl out on his phone
come on man damn that's intense
step-by-step manual
a text saying I'm going to break up with
her soon I just need to figure out how
wow
yeah nice Peak uh I would hate so much
to read that um so would I I'd really
really hate to read that so would I
because that's just the rugs yeah traits
from under your feet yeah facts just oh
and obviously you have to break up with
him on that facts bro
damn Bank transfers from my girlfriend
to him
to him him he's really him he's really
him he knows who he is as well so she's
funding next man's lifestyle ah Bank
transfers
ah livid pictures of another girl
wearing nothing by his T-shirt dying
washed an iron
[Laughter]
oh my God
washed and ironed yeah damn wow it's
just her doing that pretty yeah the
nesting spread like wow you got that
good ironing water hello
yeah
I just mind my business bills facts my
boyfriend's side chick confirming that
ultrasound appointment
fro
that
that is crazy confirming their
ultrasound appointment
and that's crazy yeah bro
I can't imagine how he would have felt
when that just the whole thing got
exposed
are you ready for that ultrasound on
Wednesday
I'll drop everything in my hands bro
everything I've mastered some pit like
babe just checking if you set an alarm
for tomorrow why what's tomorrow you're
out your ultrasound isn't it
isn't it isn't it oh unless I keep
playing I'd keep playing I'll be fine
I'd have to keep playing headphones in
yeah yeah yo yo I can't I can't really
hear you man probably said again
my heart you'd see my heart beating on
my chest I will face the TV she broke
the TV but I'll still be facing the TV
she was sat in front of me and you see
my nose bleeding
you see my nose gushing with blood
the ultrasound isn't it oh
God want the wall to swallow me oh fat
Jesus Christ that's scary man scary
hella scary Bros I checked his search
history and it said how to hide your gay
side from your girlfriend
your gay side it's not even your whole
identity it's just a side okay aside
from your girlfriend wow that would
don't break my heart it yes because he's
trying his best yeah it's it's pig bro
it's like do you feel
do you is it is it a mixture of betrayal
like sadness for yourself sadness for
them a mixture of like was it me that
changed you like yeah like there's so
many yeah so many questions you want to
tell him just go [__] a guy bro I know
like in this whole hide in yourself like
do what you need to do do what you need
to do and come back or don't yeah yeah
don't don't come back don't come back my
ex-boyfriend had hundreds of pics of
himself doing duck lips just like doing
up
oh dear yeah that's a lot he was
subscribed to his sister's only oh okay
let's not do this him Googling photos of
period sex whilst we're at a bar
foreign
oh that's making me feel sick my sex
tape not filmed with him oh
that's Peak
that's Pig
that's very big she found that on Whose
phone my sex tape not filmed with him
she found a video of her yeah get banged
by a next man on his phone his phone
so it's it's twofold it's either he's
waiting for the right time to broach the
topic to tell her about it or he's bash
into this yeah and a fantasy yeah he's
fascinated on a cocktail yeah I love
seeing my girl getting absolutely bring
this up
yucky toenail picks not the manicured
ones but the infected
the fungus ones yeah then yellow thick
ones yeah oh you know this thing oh you
know they stick yeah facts
him DM him celebrities on IG saying what
you doing like say he's gonna get a
response plural celebrities bro what are
you doing what are you doing WYD
mad so embarrassing so embarrassing
that's one thing because that's like my
secret little play time yeah
that's my secret or play time so if
you're gonna don't beef me about it yeah
don't beef and don't expose me yeah yeah
just leave me to it man it's my happy
place yeah facts because one day one
might reply facts and you never know uh
male moaning ASMR on my boyfriend's
phone
mad my credit card information
yeah you know you know your life's
ruined if your credit card information
is on their phone peek that's horrible
that is horrible
voice notes to his side chick one week
after sending out our wedding
invitations oh my God I bet they weren't
condolences either
I bet this voice definitely weren't
condolences I'm still gonna have free
time man why are you why are you acting
up it's the marriage yeah it's for
Instagram I want to keep my mom happy
man like my family man relax bro come on
man you know what you mean to me
come on man and you know I have to marry
a Muslim you know that you know that I
have to marry a Muslim it's a religious
it's a religious
come on man I'll see you next weekend as
promised stop being silly stop being
silly give me a kiss man yeah
matter of fact will you wear it but if I
show me man is it matching yeah yeah
come on man
all right last one a crazy thing you
found in someone's fault
found out my dad was cheating on my mum
told my mum and she said I know
the mums always know middle-aged wives
they know they just shut up about it
and they get effects when the kids bring
it up oh
I don't need you to tell me man that
would be my worst nightmare me
unbeknownst and my kid comes comes to me
and says Dad Dad scared crying Dad mom's
cheating on you I'll be like what I mean
what do you even know about all these
well you know about cheating I'm not
cheating and what do you think cheating
is your mother what's your mother you're
talking about respect her but also pass
me your phone yeah well what do you tell
me what you know what do you know
because that that oh I'd break it down
you have to say face you can't see yeah
you can't drop your knees
as soon as he learns how close I'm I'm
holding up yeah
he leaves like you scream daddy you're
all right
I'll take a couple seconds
yeah yeah go outside I said go outside
okay
look it up I said go outside
like Dad what are you doing on the floor
stand up or something stand up arise I
dropped a contact go outside yeah [__]
bro all my days long oh you see claw
marks in the carpet yeah long long long
that's that's a that's a nightmare
that's a huge nightmare that's always a
massive one it reminds me of um I don't
know why it reminds me of this sometimes
I think it's because we're in La we
listen to it and I hadn't listened to it
the first time the the Justin Timberlake
what goes around comes back around when
Scarlet JoJo's just banging his bedroom
oh yeah yeah I don't know why in that
three minute music video I got upset
for JT I was upset because the bridge
wasn't even laying he was just any brand
some chubby done bro some alcoholic
bread yeah and just move into TT's girl
bro and she's having it he was having it
she was fully having it from jump
mad mad that was a that was that was
such an album it was a future sex love
something
yeah I'm pretty sure yeah that's that's
from future sex love sounds such an
album
yeah um
[Music]
anyway
um welcome to the show guys welcome back
welcome back welcome back was that the
last one nice what's the last one yeah
fair play
um real quick guys because I know like
40 of you are American This Is Us I've
literally never had Mountain Dew it
tastes like
original Lucas Aid oh they're different
flavors is there I'm sure there are this
is the original flavor I'm assuming yeah
yeah just green I'm sure there are
different flavors bro socks this is
so [__] elsewhere and it's got so much
sugar in it and it tastes awful and
obviously I'm drinking because of no
other option at this point but
I'm not impressed what is what flavor is
it meant to be giving like you want to
try yeah let me Skype it is it like lime
or something yeah yeah obviously Sky it
it's Buzz right yeah I see what you're
saying about the Lucas 18. original
Lucas it just tastes like nothing yeah
and there's hardly any Fizz yeah which
is weird I know it's because I shook it
yeah but still
it's a weird drink yeah it's it's
actually awesome dead actually very
awesome but I'm sure there are different
flavors there needs to be something but
anyway welcome back guys thank you for
coming back and joining us on this
beautiful Monday the weather is starting
to Peak a little bit it was a little bit
overcast earlier but uh we're having a
few rays of sunshine it's a 30 drizzle
um 19 humidity today in London
um 21.5 degrees Celsius and uh
you are chilling here with your boys
J Money and firelord flags and we're
here to hit you with another juicy juicy
episode of shifts and gigs standard uh
episode 291 we're slowly closing on
episode 300.
um I'm trying to do my Anchorman voice
today yeah
uh we're closing on episode 300 guys and
it would be really really nice if you
just want to like gift us like 200 000
Subs by the time we get to episode 300
that would round us up to a Peng Milli
yeah and it would just be one wholesome
celebration so we don't need to
celebrate twice thanks
but anyway obviously guys you know what
I'm getting at if you are watching on
YouTube please please please please
please please subscribe to the channel
we really really really really really
really really really really really want
that million just click the button bro
just it facts it's a little red thing
just
yeah man just flicked that yeah um and
it will mean it means nothing to you
means everything to us so please uh jump
on that
um if you're listening on any of the
audio platforms Spotify Apple podcast
etc etc please leave us a nice review
follow the page and um guys if you want
to indoctrinate yourself if you actually
want to be part of the family family if
you want to feel good on a day-to-day
basis
you need to head on over to patreon.com
shits and gigs and give your daddy's
three pound a month MP a day run the
pita SMG so that we can grow this
we can cultivate this grow this let's
start Implement implementing brick and
mortar it doesn't have to be a screen to
screen text it's a brick and mortar
thing and over a patreon whilst you're
waiting for that brick and mortar you
can binge three years worth of episodes
you can jump in the Discord you get
early access to Live show tickets you
get any access to merch you get early
access to literally anything that's
going on
um and you get exclusive rights to a
cheeky little sum that's going to be
coming out in the next few months okay
facts so I'm not gonna say too much but
it's something juicy coming down the
next few months that's all I'm gonna do
I'm planting seeds accountability seeds
yeah man bro they need to grow right
guys so it is time for that stupid
little game we call top five top five
because I'm tired of just the the
misleading the deceit all right all
right there's a lies I'm not even
grabbing on my board until you tell me
what's going on
um let me even remember what the today's
top five is Fam I'm thirsty and I don't
want to drink this anymore there's no
water in there what else is there
there's alcohol oh the apple juices and
there's old apple juice
fermented apple juice bro anyway what is
it largest countries by size that's easy
that's there's no maths around it
there's no wiggle room it's just country
so is this like just land mass yeah are
you saying yeah do you know it is it is
largest countries by size that's all it
is it's all it is that's all it is I'm
logged in am I confident another
question I'm not really confident Jimmy
you're locked I'm locked I've I've
actually don't care anymore you do I
know I do but you do care I'm not taking
that bit all right one thing I I guess
you'll clarify when you do it but one
thing I wanted to write but did
everyone's locked right yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay one thing I wanted to clarify
about I didn't I wanted to put
Antarctica okay because I know that's a
big big land mass but I don't think it's
country I don't think it has a flag no
it's it's just it's just like it's a
continent though class is a continent
yeah so I don't that and there's no
countries in it that doesn't count cool
I didn't write it okay cool that doesn't
count all right I put USA Russia
China Australia and Brazil yeah uh REM
might not the exact same I swear exactly
prove it son Alice Russia USA Australia
Canada and Germany Canada's pretty big
country that's a good shot I was gonna
write Canada I don't know why I didn't
but China so cheap China by number but
it doesn't necessarily mean because I
was going to write Nigeria but that's
number yeah it doesn't necessarily mean
land yeah right from 10 first
um
um Russia obviously okay Canada
I was gonna write Canada well done Ellis
all right Ellis go third China yeah yeah
fourth USA so everyone's a three at the
moment yeah yeah last
one two three four five Australia
everyone's actually everyone's got four
wow there's only one left no tell a lie
tell a lie tell a lie I was carrying it
in wrong way so I said I said Russia I
said Canada China I said China you said
Australia I said Australia and I said I
said America right yeah discount
Australia Australia is sixth oh so fifth
is Brazil I got Brazil Brazil
so so we're all tied you're all tied on
four oh my days so I need to do
that's why I didn't do you that's what I
didn't do from 10. so I don't want to be
that guy yeah
but
REM didn't actually write USA he wrote
North America which is a Content I'm not
country I'm just gonna say that
oh my I don't want to be that guy if
we're actually VAR and the thing North
America is a continent if we're VAR in
the tank whatever it I'm sorry in it if
we are sorry it's doggy dog he was a fan
of zombies
North America is U.S and Canada collated
Fair all right cool I expect that from
scom from scum yeah
so you're forfeiting that yes so that
means you've got three so so it's a tie
breaker between uh REM and REM Jimmy and
Ellis and now are ready to give you
mount Australia obviously always give me
the rest the other four all right Ellis
let's go with you okay so I've got
Nigeria yeah I'm sticking with Germany
still New Zealand that was just like a
panic one
Afghanistan I don't even think about
Middle East James
I've got Japan South Africa Nigeria
Indonesia oh yeah it's done for you yeah
you I don't know yeah you've got it I
don't know I'll let the game master
speak come on I'm shaking I thought I
didn't care about it
I don't care about anything else else
okay I'm gonna tell you what
seven to ten are okay so obviously I've
given you Australia yeah
which was six number seven is India
India oh my God literally stupid
are you stupid are you so competitive
are you actually [__] dumb bro so bae
literally it was there it is [__] sake
oh for God's sake man number eight
Argentina I was gonna write Argentina
I was actually gonna write Argentina bro
but you did it bro whatever man what's
the rest number nine Kazakhstan a number
10 Algeria so none of you got seven to
ten okay but the closest I'm Gonna Keep
yeah okay number eleven how embarrassing
India man number 11 Congo
number 12 Saudi Arabia damn okay number
13. Mexico I was gonna write Mexico
number 14. one of you put this down as
well one of you put number 14 okay and
one of you get the point it's gonna be
Alice drumroll drumroll
and the country is
Indonesia oh [__] yeah [__] then it goes
Sudan Libya Iran Mongolia Peru Chile oh
yeah you you stayed with Germany and you
failed with Germany yeah literally
say you get that one point bite my hair
like an anonymous it's an embarrassment
yeah so it's not part of that point five
five two we go again next week Jesus
this is get India bro yeah India India
should have potentially been in some of
our top five yes yeah it should have
been in the top five yeah never mind six
to ten yeah there we go you're not
saying you every day guys
let's take a really really really quick
break to keep the lights on yes so guys
you already know summer's around the
corner are you ready to unveil your
Beach pod open-ended question
my Escape is here to ensure that your
body's ready for the wild with their
game changing full body grooming and
hygiene products let's go don't be the
guy at the beach with Austin Powers
chest hair and if you grew some winter
man tits blood clots the least you can
do is make sure they're hairless facts
it's time to get ready for hot guy
Summer by going to manscape.com and use
the code sng Sierra November gold for 20
off and free shipping thank you guys
let's get back to the episode what's up
guys right let's take a very very very
quick break from the episode to talk to
you about something as close to our
hearts it's called love honey come on
real quick you're wondering who's love
honey I'm gonna tell you love honey is
an award-winning online retailer and
designer of sex toys and lingerie guys
yeah the redefine it enormous around sex
and what sexy means and it's taboos as
well right guys first up this is the
world famous womanizer premium 2 this is
an air suction thing
it's the air suction toy and I'm hearing
that these air suction toys are changing
the game and this is the flagship toy
for this technology guys so this is most
recommended just by Word of Mouth facts
Word of Mouth bro say less but guys if
you know you know facts jump in right
guys next we have the We Vibe Nova 2.
this is like a rabbit on steads
stop it stance babes like it's it's got
the constant clitoral connection the
constant collateral touch you put one in
and then this bit here that the silicone
yeah just a smooth to the touch once it
slides in ladies you're gonna have a
fantastic time this is rendering man
useless that's what I'm saying ladies
you're gonna have a fantastic time just
remember the three C's that constant
clitoral connection or contact even it's
gonna be Breezy last but not least guys
you can see over here we've got the arc
wave power bro indeed The Arc wave power
bro it's a premium manual Stroker and
this has got suction control and dual
entry if you want to flip the flip if
we're if we're flipping them yeah yeah
we're flipping we're having a party yeah
that's crazy the final face took this
for a spin the other day and he said it
was nuts yeah yeah so guys jump in grab
that okay guys so if you want to get
involved well when you want to get
involved all you need to do is head on
over to lovehoney.co.uk and use the code
giggs20 okay that's gigs 20. perfect
g-i-g-s number two number zero right
guys jump in and let us know how you get
on facts let's get back to the episode
right we're moving on to an am I the
[__] yeah me age 20 and my girl 21
both main college and we've been
together for about three years in the
beginning we were like rabbits always
intimate with each other fast forward
two years with fast forward two years
and it started to die off and I really
don't know the reason why it was like
three times a month then I Christmas of
last year we found out she was pregnant
and at the time I told her that I wasn't
ready I wasn't financially mentally or
emotionally ready for a baby I thought
we came to an arrangement that we
weren't ready for a baby but then in
like two weeks she decided that she
wanted to keep it regardless of the
repercussions and said it was against
her belief big man she ain't had no
beliefs before that
but anyways back on topic after she was
like three months pregnant we had sex
twice and after that he was dead which I
think he's trying to say okay no sex for
the whole pregnancy and I was told some
women don't really have sex when they're
pregnant but fast forward our baby is
six months and still nothing no head
barely any kissing I confronted her
about it and she said she really isn't a
sexual person oh but I said it wasn't
like that in the beginning and she's and
she said that was then
Ahmadi also for wanting to find it
somewhere else sorry if it was a long to
summarize blah blah blah so it was like
nine ten months with no sex with my
partner and we were always on each other
I'm thin and boys help me out so seeing
him he's feeding
summary he's 20 and she's 21. uh they've
been dating for three years or they were
together for three at the very awesome
um they were together for three years
always they were always [__] like
rabbits fast forward two years later I
started to die off and they were having
sex a couple times a month in Christmas
rolling around they found out she was
pregnant he wasn't ready financially
mentally or emotionally for the baby
um they came to they thought they were
going to come to agreement she was like
[__] it I'm gonna keep the baby because
of my beliefs he's saying big man he
didn't have beliefs in the first place
um they had sex a couple times during
the pregnancy
um and then fast for six months after
the baby was born still no head no
nothing no touching barely any kissing
he confronted her she said I'm not
really a sexual person and she is saying
oh
um but sorry he said oh it wasn't like
that in the beginning you see the
[__] for trying to find it somewhere
else
um obviously in my opinion it depends
how about he how he goes about finding
it somewhere else of course
um if you're gonna be upfront
to be like big man
I'm here for it I think I told I I think
I told you this when I was like 17 and
stuff like that I was going out with
like a Christian girl and she said I
think I want to be celibate
and I was like well obviously you want
to be single in Santa yeah because I'm
not I'm not doing it yeah yeah and she
was like what she was like wow you
actually don't love me at all and I'm
like I love you dearly yeah I thought I
did yes yeah um I love you dearly yeah
yeah I'm a human being it's important to
me I don't want to have a girlfriend
where I'm just chit chatting and fapping
at home yeah that's dead it is dead and
I feel it's very very different if you
guys have both come to a mutual
agreement you're both like faithful or
religious or you're trying to go on this
journey together and you both come to it
to an agreement and say let's be
celibate for x and see how long we can
do right if you want your own go your
separate way and be like you you get
into a relationship you've been begging
you've been bagging and folks then
tomorrow all of a sudden oh I'm I'm
gonna be celibate but we're still
together by the way yeah yeah but you're
the same time I'm changing the goal
posts yeah and you're just gonna have to
play this new game you're just gonna
have to fur me I love the new tactics
you uh you signed up for me for me long
term and I'm an evolving specimen yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so you best you
best evolve with me you best following
yeah no never nah bro I'll tell you I'm
looking to clap someone's cheeks or I'm
doing on goals one of the two facts bro
one of the two so you can't you can't
there's no way you can just be like Oh
I'm gonna be selling and expect my man
to be oh yeah cool whatever yeah so
she's gone I would like personally I'm
not I'm first of all
I'm not having this chit chat about I'm
not a sexual person I'm not entertaining
this chit chat for a second there's
different stages so obviously like
pre he said it was getting Butters
before she even got pregnant right yeah
so obviously post-pregnancy it's
understandable her body's changed
hormones have changed she's not getting
any sleep she doesn't feel pain there's
not there's nothing sexy about what's
going on in this house yeah we're young
and we're broke and we're dumb and we're
looking after you there's nothing sexy
about this so if you're not feeling
sexual that makes sense
um but yeah this was how he said this
was happening after two years of bang
bang bang bang and then she was like I'm
just not feeling it anymore three years
oh Jesus
um no you said there's two years of clap
in and then one year Buzz yeah yeah yeah
so yeah if that's the case I'll just
address it and she's like I'm not a
sexual person that's easy that's fine
because I obviously am so where do we go
from here in fact I'm gonna let I'm
gonna let you answer this for me yeah
yeah because I don't open yeah yeah I'm
gonna let you answers Where Do We Go
From Here Yeah because I'm a very sexual
person you can see that I clearly don't
want to go elsewhere because I've been
trying to move to you you're my girl
and it turns me on
I need you're my wife and it turns me on
what are we saying what are you doing
about it you want another one or not
yeah I'll give you anything
I got you you're fat run me that skin
fast I want you back you shouldn't be
turning me yeah I've seen you bent up
squeezing human beings out here and I
don't care I need that again I want it
again run me that what are we saying and
if you're just like now I'm not honest
you're a sexual person then I say all
right cool well Daddy needs to find some
that is thirsty a Mountain Dew ain't
cotton yeah
I'm doing covering it yeah Mountain Dew
and cotton it bro and it's something
else and it's something hydrating facts
man so what what what are we gonna do
how are we gonna work this out we're
gonna address this yeah yeah and if she
answers oh but babe but you're not
banging anyone else banging anyone it's
just me you know
I guess I guess we're gonna have to part
where is also an open relationship and
this is the thing as well like I want to
know that's the thing I I have to I have
to hear the whole story yeah because
this is I'm not a sexual person yeah
it's like all right cool let's just have
like a judgment free conversation yeah
and big man Ting if we break up and if
you find someone else because I'm
assuming you like being in a
relationship you like yeah yeah guys
yeah yeah yeah
you better go in there telling them
you're not a sexual person and if if you
can't be honest with me don't lie to me
and say yeah I'm gonna do that look me
in my face because it's basically done
now anyway yeah so just tell me anyway
like if you find someone else are you
gonna are you gonna find that itch again
or is it me because if it's me I'd
rather just know this tell me yeah yeah
don't lie to me and say it's like we've
had this conversation before when he
said oh I don't like sucking dick oh you
just don't like sucking Mighty yeah you
like sucking someone's you like someone
sucking someone's there yeah yeah come
on bro because yeah like I'll do
anything for someone that I'm attracted
to facts I'll bury my face in the ass
fat I'll bury my face in there [__] but
if I'm not I'm not just I'm not a
notorious ass eater facts but run me the
right skin [__] diving so I can't not
say I'm not a sexual person yeah
because find me the right song yeah and
I'm gonna do something yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm a free upside
yeah facts so yeah it's uh I need you to
tell me it's me because I'm certain is
because we had two years of launch it
definitely has to be me and just tell me
that I'd rather you tell me the truth
and then don't just hide behind the guys
of us having a baby and you say not
sexual and all of this and all of that I
get it but just tell me bro tell me
because it only allows oh hurt me but it
allows us both
I'll start taking steroids do everything
I'll do everything I'm drinking bare
water every day I'll be sleeping right
because I don't have to deal with this
[__] oh and I I
dare you to tell me your sexual um
growth has come back I when you when you
see me see me you're not coming to pick
up our son yeah hey Dave I'm trying to
scratch myself yeah I dare you yeah I'll
SWAT your hands I'm a stone heavier yeah
yeah I'm so heavier I'm just using plant
made all over everything I'm listening
always there's not a bag under these
eyes if I get my eight hours facts oh my
blemishes Crystal skin and my money's up
come home the kids miss you
I would have to come back
again bro
I was just imagine that opening the door
in like a nice yeah maybe done smelling
buff yeah she's had the whole weekend to
herself to pamper herself up I'm
dropping off Junior I said you want to
stay for a bit oh I do want I put the
kettle on do you want a little slime do
you want something do you want to say
it's a nice sunny day man I've got some
pims outside yeah come to the Garden you
remember the garden yeah come on man
just relax it's an excuse me excuse the
cross that's another man's touching on
what
we need a man around here we get lost in
it yeah why don't we try [__]
facts
facts should be doing things she ain't
done in three years yeah yeah you bought
her back you bought her back and she's
holding another unit
starts all over again
I'd bury a knife
Barry you might not enough
just roll off another yard anyway
because you're later with her legs in
the F ages
[Music]
I'll draw for the shower head
straight all over
Oh my days bro Oh my days but yeah wait
[__] um he wants to [__] anyone else
do what you need to do but as long as
you guys have had the conversation if
you if you [__] her behind if you [__]
someone else behind her back you're a
waste man you're a waste man but also
again it's it's um
what what's what's that thing you say
um ignorance is bliss added like if you
if you don't [__] up the household then
maybe but just just just have the
conversation see where it goes and then
go from there man see where it goes yeah
yeah have the conversation and then yeah
like literally see where it goes let
your intentions be known facts be 100
honest with Trevor she's like from there
yeah if she's like
I need you and I love you but I just
don't want sex and I also don't want you
banging anyone else
[Music]
yeah yeah it's long just tackling needs
yeah we're just facilitating needs bro
we're going home yeah
we're we're yeah we're getting the
poison out and we're going home
getting good eight hours and running it
back tomorrow night oh my God this is
Christ he didn't get that far by the way
said again he didn't get that far she
found messages in his phone and they had
to lock it off no where's this yeah
that's he sent two separate messages so
I I sent to Forex the first bit and I
saw it underneath the second bit he said
oh actually yes can you read it for us
she I haven't got it here oh okay quick
little screenshot I did two for the
first bit but yeah yeah literally three
sentences was just like yeah actually
she found messages on my phone had to
love it so he didn't have the
conversation he just went the Wormy way
yeah yeah he tried to go he was on his
way to go to facilitate something
facilitate the needs but he didn't get
that far she clocked it and what
happened she locked it she locked it and
he said I just don't even know what to
do now damn he should have waited for
our response bro yeah he didn't even
wait should have waited for the response
bro jonesing bro yeah that's like that's
not even oh he said that this month he
could have waited
bro sorry G my bad Bros it's all right
that's not
this is
just texting yeah
yeah but he's hungry bro of course he's
hungry but come on man wait yeah you've
been waiting years true wait a few more
weeks we're gonna get there that's true
true Jesus all right there you go that
is what it is all right um I've got a
quick thread what was the quickest job
you quit and how long I worked at a
liquor store and quit after four hours
uh one of the customers yelled at me
because he asked for a bottle that was
on the left side and I turned to the
right because it was literally my first
day so obviously I didn't know where the
[__] was the manager miscounted my toe
and yelled at me when I told her
first of all man said he doesn't know
his left and right this is the first day
no no
bro
he the my man asked for a bottle which
was on the left but she walked to the
right because obviously she didn't know
where the bottle was because it was her
first day not not her not knowing what
her left and right is oh I see I thought
you were saying
hey asked for something that's on the
left can I get the bottle on the left
and she turned to the right it's just
like obviously I don't know it's my
first day
[Laughter]
and the customer said what are you doing
what are you doing it's over there
I would have been so struck struck I'll
take my apron what's all this bro stop
shouting at me all right two and a half
days the only time I've quit like that
door-to-door sells in a wealthy
neighborhood except it was a about
people changing over for more cheaper
and environmental friendly electricity
here we go it literally benefited them
got screamed at by an old man for being
a liar and a [__]
is it a guy or a girl do you know a girl
wrote this being a liar and a [__] what
a liar and a [__] we're trying to Liar
man it's not cheaper you're a liar tell
man some some electricity wow you're on
my doorstep selling skin
you [__] get away from me before my
before my wife sees
yeah come on come on tell me something
yeah send me something I'll sign up I
got money for you
quit a job at CVS two minutes after my
first day during college the manager
said this is the busiest CVS in the
Southeast region I said okay I left
facts it's not a turn on it's not a
turtle you can't tell me it's the most
quiet facts bro Let Me ease into it yeah
it's the business even South East region
no no no no no no no no no no I'm out
I'm immediate that's a lot of pressure
oh you're out that's jokes worked at
this freezer warehouse for one and a
half for one and a half minutes I was in
the cooler freezing my ass to death and
she was like are you ready to go in the
freezer I said what the [__] region are
we in she was like oh that's just the
cooler the freezer is ice cold I took my
warm suit over left
what the [__] are we in bro because I
knew you would say what the [__]
this is a cooler the freezer's ice cold
this is not a working environment fast
it's not working environment no I'm not
going in the freezers to be involved nah
bro facts
uh this guy put Bed Bath and Beyond I
left during my lunch they wanted me to
climb ladders
oh my God I worked at Urban Outfitters
Urban Outfitters for two days one was
training and one was on the floor that
was enough for me they still haven't
paid me
damn Hospitality
um retail is long retail's the worst
retail is long
um I quit Smoothie King after two weeks
where trauma dump manager didn't give me
the keys to open I was opening up by
myself and then I had to yell at a
customer about something so I just
walked out they weren't [__] up my
new beginnings and not pay me enough for
all the drama damn bro New Beginnings
you know that's how you know you're
trying to turn a new Leaf
quit Chick-fil-A on a college campus
after not quitting after not getting a
lunch break
my manager never taken into account I
had classes and my boss trying to
guilt-trip me into staying because I
can't just quit into in the real world
like babes this is just a Chick-fil-A
I hate when they come with that
condescending [__] you can't just
quit in the real world you know watch me
I could do what I want
what's me it's my life this is the real
world facts bro am I working yes or no
the real world I do what I want when I
want oh God I worked at Taco Bell for
six hours the men in the kitchen were
thirsty
once they call me fresh meat
bro women
I've been in the belly of the
hospitality beast and women just get
they get moved to and talk to like their
actual scrant really especially
especially the chefs like the female
chefs or the chefs of the bastards so
female chefs get it yeah and the male
chefs are Pricks oh God male chefs act
like this
you know it I like male chefs act like
they've never seen a woman before I
swear yeah because obviously nine times
out of ten well seven to eight times out
of ten a lot of a lot of kitchens aren't
open kitchens they're like either
underground you can't see the kitchen
yeah yeah yeah yeah basically but the
ones that are open Oh my days chefs act
like they've just not seen titty before
or they've not had gal before it's crazy
and they just say just mad sexy stuff
they say the maddest thing maybe
obviously not to the women but to the
other men around them and obviously I'm
privy to hearing a lot of stuff Jesus
it's crazy bro some of the stuff that
they say some of the stuff that they say
they want to do to these women
is Alice you know right I'm not chatting
I'm not trying to [__] it's crazy bro
the [__] animals honestly animals
Bros
animals I think it's because they've
been stuck they're stuck in like a
kitchen and like
chefs are sneaky because chefs chefs
find a good way to get pum yeah but most
chefs always have wives or girlfriends
so what they do is if they let's say for
example um let's say I'm a thing right
let's say I'm the chef yeah I'm the chef
you're a new thing and you even I knew
you were going to switch it let's say
I'm the chef and you're a new thing yeah
yeah I've got a message whatever
whatever I'm doing my team I'm head chef
but I've seen you you're like a new
receptionist yeah yeah uniform I'm just
eager to please yeah you're eager to me
and you're looking good you're looking
hip thick and you're Universe I'm
dressing up yeah yeah it's your first
day first I need to impress everyone my
hair is smelling amazing everything yep
yeah walking around you're learning
everything someone's teaching you and
stuff a lot you that person let's say
REM works for me already or works in the
restaurant already rem's introducing you
to everyone because you're the Newbie
right REM introducing you to me like hi
I'm too high I'm head chef blah blah
blah blah and you know I'll just do a
little Ting Ting Ting you know and as
days go by our hours go by I'll be like
anything you need just let me know if
you're hungry let me know if you need
anything just let me know I'm the HF I
can show you I can look after you you'd
get me with the hungry you could Outlook
after you yeah you're getting one day
you'll come in now you start your shift
let's say you got morning shift right or
let's say you've got a morning shift
you've not eaten you're you're just
running through you can check you use
one of them ones where you're just busy
shuffling have a little break you're
ready for you on the side that's tasty
do you know what I'm saying yeah yeah
you're hungry for lunch he's not gonna
make anyone else food whatever but he'll
make you a little something on the side
okay girlfriend you've got a girlfriend
I'm thinking why is he doing this for me
but it's how he gets you yeah yeah yeah
as a chef I'm quick with a banter I'm
flirtatious man this is my lifestyle
yeah yeah I mean it's normal yeah you're
in the kitchen you can take the heat I
can literally take it yeah no one's
looking down at me yeah I'm looking up
at it yeah yeah you run this whole
establishment dance no one can chat [__]
you need anything come talk to me
imma give you food every day
every day you're hungry I got you you
thirsty I'll ask someone at the
bartenders get your little Sun
Friday Friday I'm cooking now that's how
it happens bro yeah keep feeding me so
so like I like Star parties or like when
everyone goes out as a group then you
actually connect when you're letting the
hair down exactly yeah I see you add
them whites yeah yeah yeah yeah grab
your drink at which loss and we go from
there that's too cheeky exactly yeah
that's how it happens right there
already right yeah damn yeah
and then I yeah then I bang you you
blame me facts bro I got a girlfriend
and it's awkward yeah yeah I've got a
girl for a few days you seduced me
you've got family at home it's awkward
for a few days I know they run it back
and find a new Target that's bro they
run it back for fighting in Target
all of a sudden I'm not getting dishes
anymore
yeah and I want to know what's coming
yeah all of a sudden you've got an
attitude yeah you're gonna get lunch
anymore yeah you're just giving me apple
slices yeah I'm I'm talking over you I'm
talking to the group now I'm not focused
on you anymore when we're doing taste
tests and stuff I'm skipping you okay
see that's I've got a new Target yeah
nah that's scary hours bro that's what
these men do when you're willing to play
nuts I might run your feedback again
okay see now you can't do that to me hey
are you hungry aren't you yeah
you know
with that plum sauce you know it's my
favorite you son of a [__] like that
before somebody stuck Charlie yes say
less I made it fresh yeah as a new yeah
careful it's hot
oh stuff
I can't remember what you're talking
about bro what were we talking about wow
quitting jobs [__] yeah I don't know how
we got on this yeah we need help wow
that's twice in one episode wow all
right spinner from the question
um have you guys ever how what's the job
you've quit like I'll go last because we
know where this is going I don't think
rem's ever quit his job in his life he's
done a great job
well he has obviously yeah I left that
spot where you're getting kids back yoga
in my mouth I left there well you were
there for for a minute about 18 months
yeah oh wow I came down to London to
live in London yeah fair play oh so you
only quit because you were moving yeah
okay if I ever moved to London I would
still be there now
honestly all my jobs
I was stuck uh with them for like
minimum for like two years
genuinely uh my first ever job I got I
was like 15. stayed there till I was 70.
it's crazy yeah boring man I yeah that's
not boring bro yeah but it is a bit
because like loads of people I've met
like my age and stuff Jesus they've had
jobs like lows they've tried everything
um yeah there's ways bro mine mine was
the um door-to-door sales thing oh yeah
how long how long did you do that for
not long bro I remember I did it the
summer of
third year so it's when we all lived in
Grafton is it Grafton yeah so the summer
before we all moved into Grafton is the
summer I did that door-to-door sales
because I came back to Cove like a month
early I remember something like that and
I was wondering yeah I was living that
yard that cold yard a cold [__]
Barren empty yard I remember right now
you're just listening to Ed Sheeran
that's all I remember
you're the patchy bed you listen to Ed
Sheeran no internet and a swollen dick
that's all I had going for me I was
fapping bro bro I remember you said
because you draw a tin rounds and I
remember you bought someone around I
know I don't remember you met a certain
person right yeah yeah
he said she slaps you off and you said
stop
oh is it yeah yeah yeah
I remember
I remember I remember you said you were
blosky bro when you you let her come
through she was a cough local you know
who it is bro
oh now I
now exactly what you're talking about I
can't remember the scenario I remember
I remember it's the same day I saw you
listen to Ed Sheeran Oh my days Yeah
well yeah you have yeah that was a few
weeks she's done for right or was it
less than that less probably less I did
I remember doing the induction and
everything and I was guessed about
obviously you know my money man when it
comes to figures you tell me something
about money I'm interested yeah yeah um
but they'll like you have to go door to
door to door and this and he said the
commission is bathroom blah blah blah I
can't remember for the life of me what I
was selling but I did it once with
someone so I was chaperone or they were
I was chaperoning them and they was
going door to door to doors just so I
can get the routine of things
um that I did it once by myself I
remember and it's somewhat of a script
you have to do so I was fumbling what I
had to say yeah I can't be asked for
this yeah yeah I'm not embarrassing
myself every door yeah every door every
door
I've quit jobs yeah of course so I quit
I think the shortest one I did
the shortest one I did most of the jobs
I've quit were these like summer jobs I
did similar to your door-to-door I used
to all I think I told you around before
I used to always my mum would always
make me work in a warehouse yes yes yes
so where in Northampton there's bare
warehouses bro bear factories bear
warehouses
um and like obviously certain parts of
the country you live in there's bear
there's always that bear of one thing
yeah
um so people always get jobs doing a
certain thing based on the city you're
in Northampton warehouses bro so
um all it is is just like loading
lorries or like packing boxes and like
having it shipped off just Warehouse
[__] bro
um
one time I didn't even make it to the
first shift yeah
I I went in there one summer and this
was probably like third year because I
was it was like one of them ones where
it's like this is the third year on a
truck I mean third or fourth year and I
try me forced to do this yeah yeah yeah
I got a job
to get my mom for my back
it was working nights
the first night they called me in yeah I
drove to a car park and just chilled
there oh so my mom was gonna work drove
to a car park and went to sleep in my
car bro wow really couldn't do it I
couldn't do it bro I was dressed up and
my hive is and my boots you drove to a
car park go to the empty car park
reclined and slept
I would have told my mom I'm not going
dangerous Behavior bro there was no
there was no I said my mama I'm not
going I promise you there was no telling
my mom I'm not coming I went there on my
first day yeah slept
down there because it was agency work
they bail you when they want you yeah so
I went to that first day came back like
eight in the morning next day mum was
like oh how was it and I'm like oh it
was hard man yeah it was [__] hard
she was like oh well I'm proud of you
I'm like gang safe went up to bed
pretended to sleep yeah I was awake yeah
pretend to sleep till my mom won't work
gallivant the whole day yeah they bailed
me again the next day hang up the phone
my mom said well I go and work I said
Mom they're not Bellamy yeah yes agency
yeah she was like you need to build I
need to chase them I was like Mom I am
I'm betting I've been Bellingham yeah
yeah yeah I want to work yeah I need the
money I need the money you see what I'm
I'm dealing with facts yeah I need the
money and they're just not calling me
it's just like oh [__] fair enough
[__] fair enough skipped around the
summer schedule I had no picture on my
car but I skipped around bro couldn't do
it so that was the shortest one I didn't
even make it today one yeah the next one
was another agency team where some guy
was just being rude to me bro yeah uh
another Warehouse thing it was at uh
like it was like a Parcel Service
so they had a bad letters I think for
Royal Mouse it might be for Royal mails
it was like Apostle service that this
machine with a million letters yeah and
then basically it will dive it goes into
postcode order and it's got this huge
[__] machine it's bigger than this
whole room and you have to like run and
then it's got like 10 rows all across
all the way there and brother you've got
to run up and down this machine because
it as it sorts the letters into postcode
like it could fit like 10 letters per
little box so you have to be like empty
put that in a box wait for the next one
empty you're running for like eight
hours oh my God and then if too many
boxes get full yeah the machine backs up
yeah and it starts going and then you
have to get bear people over to start I
know anything it happened like four
times in the space of ten minutes for
you yeah
that's something brother was like what
are you doing bro it's a Polish bro yeah
yeah I swear I would have been swayed I
was sweating I was like when does it
slow down and he was like bro we're just
getting started and it was the first
hour of the day
you've got to be joking me you've got to
be joking I'm not doing this anymore bro
and then like he was like and you're
putting him he went through the box yeah
and he was like ah Dash the letters oh
is that they're in the wrong order Oh my
days and I said can't you read English
yeah and that's when I was like excuse
me trigger yeah excuse me you're gonna
[__] out my face bro
I went Ham on him yeah I know I remember
you I remember saying I will knock you I
will literally knock you out can I read
English I can't understand what you're
saying to me
about
I walked out that day yeah I bet bro I
took off my head is bro
um yeah it's it's horrible
I got two more of the from the Fred and
we'll wrap up all right cool
um
so she said this one said McDonald's I
quit after like a month on my last day
some lady threw her food at me and I
couldn't take it anymore
threw her food at me Pete
um Chipotle worked one day my friend
told me you smelled like Chipotle and I
never went back
oh that's hilarious bro 90 of them were
fast food yeah facts fast food people go
through it yeah yeah I'm not working at
fast food I've done fast food but
obviously you worked at restaurants
worked in retail tried to do this door
to door thing yeah I've done something
I've done a few things but I did the
bartending locked that off but they
sacked me yeah because I just wasn't
coming in
um it sacked me Deloitte sacked you boy
um where else have I worked
I did the last job obviously before I
did this full time yeah sales thing
sacked that off obviously to do this
yeah boy I've quit everything yeah I've
quit everything I ever did
apart from this yeah this is the longest
job I've ever had I'm just deep in it
now this is the longest job I've ever
had
um
this probably is the longest job I've
ever had as well
yeah I was in
I was in Grill of the market for under
three years australasia for under three
years I'd be fun three years yeah and
we've been doing this for three years
plus yeah it's a long shot wow context
wow it's nice it's bright guys I think
that's a nice sign up that's a nice
thank you very much guys we appreciate
you happy Monday
um enjoy the rest of your weekend
[Music]